mais d'abord ce grand paradoxe de
l'enseignement français c'est le premier
budget de l'état et pourtant nos profs
sont moins bien payés que la moyenne
européenne sagna de chiens
les professeurs français sont parmi les
moins bien payés d'europe prenons
l'exemple d'un professeur en primaire
avec 15 ans d'expérience en france il
touche en moyenne un peu moins de
quarante mille euros brut par an soit
dix mille euros de moins que la moyenne
européenne est deux fois moins qu'en
allemagne
un retard qui inquiète désormais aussi
la droite gérard longuet a examiné le
budget éducation 2022 son rapport dresse
un constat sévère sur les conditions de
rémunération des enseignants le
quinquennat précédent monsieur hollande
avait joué la quantité en avait recruté
50 mille professeurs on a dépensé de
l'argent très bien mais on n'a pas joué
sur la qualité c'est à dire encourager
les jeunes à eau est posée ce métier en
étant mieux payés au départ un constat
partagé à l'autre bout de l'échiquier
politique
depuis la rentrée un consensus semble se
dessiner pour une revalorisation des
salaires d'enseignants il ya urgence
parce que si je peux utiliser cette
formule les enseignants votent avec
leurs pieds c'est à dire que si on leur
donne pas aujourd'hui des meilleures
conditions et partiront et on aura un
énorme problème de recrutement que le
gouvernement va compenser en prenant des
contractuels vous savez moi je suis dans
un conseil d'administration d'un collège
le dernier professeur de maths il a été
pris sur le bon coin en 2021 le
gouvernement a augmenté les salaires des
enseignants en début de carrière et
prévoit de poursuivre la revalorisation
en 2022 mais on est encore loin du
compte pour le syndicat majoritaire chez
les enseignants du primaire qui
s'inquiètent de très nombreuses
démissions depuis la rentrée de
septembre par michel blanc caire n'a pas
pris la mesure de ce qui est en train de
se passer nous avons réclamé nous une
loi de programmation pluriannuelle avec
un plan sur plusieurs années pour
pouvoir justement avoir des perspectives
on en a pas actuellement on a eu des
revalorisations en 2021 en 2022 mais
après on sait pas ce qui va se passer
moins bien payés que leurs collègues
européens les professeurs français font
aussi plus d'heures d'enseignement et
ont un des taux d'encadrement les plus
faibles avec plus de 19 élèves chacun en
moyenne dans le primaire soit cinq de
plus que la moyenne européenne
le sénat au chevet les profs c'est le
thème de notre premier débat avec gérard
longuet bonsoir bonsoir vous êtes
sénateur et l ère de la muse anciens
mise défense on vous doit ce rapport on
l'a vu dans le reportage sur la
dégradation des conditions de travail
des enseignants sophie taille polluants
bonsoir bienvenue vice président de la
commission des finances membres du
groupe écologie solidarité des
territoires vous appartenait au parti
génération point s bruno cautrès vont
soir chercheur au cnrs enseignant à
sciences po au centre de recherches
politiques de sciences po et matthieu
croissandeau à mes côtés bonsoir mathieu
éditorialiste politique je reprends
quelques chiffres pour commencer
qui sont issus de votre rapport monsieur
longuet 56,5 milliards d'euros c'est le
premier budget de l'état pour
l'éducation nationale un budget en
hausse de 2,6 pour cent pour 2022 c'est
quoi votre constat général on vous a
entendu très rapidement dans dans le
sujet j'aimerais vous entendre un peu
plus longue alors le constat général au
titre de la commission des finances
savoir si nous en avons pour notre
argent la commission des finances on a
des préoccupations extrêmement modeste
savoir si l'argent public est bien
dépensé or on constate que la dépense
moyenne globale pour l'enseignement en
france est comparable aux payer
étrangers de l' ocde par exemple ou aux
pays de l'union européenne mais qu'en
revanche les résultats des élèves
semblent d'une façon constante - bon
d'année en année depuis que nous avons
généraliser pour les uns et les autres
la confrontation à partir des chiffres
de l'enquêté pisa principalement mai
mais pas seulement donc on en a ça coûte
et ça ça ne rapporte pas en qualité
alors on s'est posé la question ce
n'était pas la préoccupation précis et
la pâle l'aprem préoccupation principale
à l'origine de la commission des
finances puisque je pense ce rapport
depuis plusieurs années ces deux
basculer vers le primaire des dépenses
qui est est insuffisante et de ce point
de vue là le ministre blanc caire a fait
ce qu'il fallait on a fortifié à quelque
sorte notre primaire qui était très en
retard que ce soit en maternelle ou en
primaire puis maintenant on s'aperçoit
qu'on a des résultats qui sont médiocres
par exemple en anglais ou en
mathématiques parce que nous avons paix
nous peinons à recruter et à garder de
bons enseignants et bien feignons
recrutés sur le bon coin on entendait ça
dans notre
caricature mais ça arrive ça arrive je
confirme que cela arrive parce que les
contractuels sont indispensables et
l'éducation nationale fait comme tout le
monde
le fond du problème c'est qu'on n'a pas
réfléchi collectivement et notamment le
ministère sur la façon de faire
travailler les enseignants dans leur
dans leurs établissements ces d'un
premier sujet majeur est le deuxième
sujet auquel je m'attache moi c'est là
la hiérarchie des carrières nous avons
une fonction publique en général et
l'éducation nationale n'y échappe pas
qui valorise l'ancienneté qui valorise
les fidélités qui valorise les années
accumulé tant mieux pour moi qui chez
vieux mai
qui ne fait pas assez appel aux besoins
effectifs
dans les situations plus difficiles ou
qui ne peut pas adapter sa rémunération
au secteur où il y a pas assez de
candidats je prends l'exemple le plus
flagrant c'est l'état alors on y
reviendra sur les mathématiques
évidemment sophie tripoli auquel quel
constat vous faites vous aussi est ce
que vous dites finalement comme comme
beaucoup que les profs sont au bord de
la rupture ou doux déjà peut-être qu'ils
ont dépassé la rupture d'ailleurs parlé
de démission dans le reportage ce que je
constate c'est que ce qui fait ce qu'ils
faisaient la fierté du modèle français
les services publics sont arrivés après
des années
de néolibéralisme entre payer un point
de rupture est ce qu'on constate sur
l'école avec les démissions on le
constate aussi à l'hôpital avec
énormément de postes non pourvus on
n'arrive plus à recruter et on le
constate dans bien d'autres secteurs
donc un service public a été très
attaqué en réduire le nombre de
fonctionnaires tous voilà tout ça arrive
quelques années à avoir des conséquences
très concrètes et très réel après sur la
question particulière de l'école je
pense effectivement qu'il y a plusieurs
éléments marquants malgré un certain
nombre d'efforts qui ont été faits très
limité et on pourra en reparler de ce
gouvernement met notamment sur la
rémunération été fait notamment des
jeunes profitent notamment des jeunes
insuffisant 100 millions dans ce budget
de mesures catégorielles qui profite
plutôt jeune ce qui n'était pas le cas à
chaque collègue l'ours de la réforme
hollande sur les pcr tout à fait était
surtout aux anciens mais ce que ce que
je voulais souligner c'est que il ya eu
d'abord une absence de dialogue social
sérieux sentiment d'un mépris
extrêmement profond voire d'une reprise
en main du monde enseignant et puis je
crois que ce qui mine l'éducation
nationale c'est une absence de gestion
des ressources humaines c'est à dire
rejoignez là moi je rejoins là dessus je
pense qu'il ya peut-être aujourd'hui
dans notre société plus qu avant une
volonté de pouvoir évoluer de pouvoir
bouger danser dans son ans et pratiques
professionnelles et finalement lorsqu'on
épouser la carrière d'enseignant eh bien
on est un peu réduit à faire le même
travail en évoluant etc au fil des ans
et tout au long de sa carrière je crois
que là il ya une vraie un vrai sujet et
je crois que en termes de formation
d'évolution de carrière et de et de lien
entre
sa pratique personnelle aussi de train
de travailler mieux les intérêts les
interconnexions entre les enseignants
dans les dans les eaux au coeur des
l'idée des établissements scolaires sont
autant de choses voilà qui sont qui sont
à à mettre en place alors on va donner
moi évidemment encore une fois il s'agit
quand même de conditions de travail très
dégradées aussi en termes de santé
en termes d'accès déjà à ce que j'ai est
ce que les enseignants vous pensez
qu'ils ont accès à la salle la médecine
du travail la réponse est non donc je
crois qu'il ya beaucoup beaucoup
beaucoup beaucoup de choses qui sont
très dégradées dans l'éducation
nationale on va parler salaire aussi
dans un instant bruno cautrès comment
vous réagissez peut-être à la démarche
de la majorité l'air est ce que c'est
surprenant de voir la majorité l'air
finalement prendre la défense des
professeurs ou aller sur le terrain de
la gauche je sais pas comment il va dire
ça mais je ne sens pas les projets oui
il est enfin l'enseignement ce qui n'est
pas tout à fait la même chose sur le las
a atteint on y reviendra à ses intérêts
sur le sur le fond on peut que se
féliciter devant le le sénat qui produit
un rapport avec beaucoup de données qui
montrent effectivement une réalité
empirique que vous chiffrez avec
beaucoup de tableaux beaucoup de
graphiques beaucoup de cours beaucoup de
chiffres et donc c'est vrai que
régulièrement dans l'actualité cette
question revient la question des
rémunérations des métiers on va dire
assez qualifié de la fonction publique
est régulièrement des gens explique mais
non ce n'est pas vrai qu'en fait ça
n'est pas vrai que les enseignants sont
moins bien payés que dans le reste de
l'europe et grâce à votre rapport on a
une information extrêmement précises
extrêmement documenté donc moi quand
j'ai commencé à aller votre travail
s'était d'abord surtout beaucoup de
satisfaction de voir cette question mise
sur la table et posez moi je travaillais
dans le domaine de l'enseignement
supérieur de la recherche
on connaît les mêmes problématiques là
aussi on a eu des évolutions on peut pas
le contester et a eu aussi des efforts
budgétaires du contribuable pour mieux
rémunérer les métiers de l'enseignement
supérieur et de la recherche je pense
que beaucoup de nos téléspectateurs
seraient stupéfaits d'apprendre le
niveau de rémunération de départ d'un
chercheur du cnrs qui a fait bac +8 +10
des efforts dans sa vie à genoux et qui
démarre péniblement autour de 2500 euros
brut
donc donc il ya là quelque chose qui est
qui est tout à fait incroyable et c'est
vrai que c'est une premier ticket
transversale à plusieurs ministères et
plusieurs métiers qualifiés de la
fonction publique on pourrait parler la
rémunération j'imagine des jeunes
commissaires de police magistrats donc
voilà on a une problématique et je veux
aborder dans votre sens qui est celui-là
prometic ressources humaines il ya
vraiment un vrai souci effectivement
ressources humaines
l'état est incontestablement un très bon
employeur je sais pas moi qui vais la
contester je suis fonctionnaire d'état
mais je dirais que c'est vrai que la
question de la gestion des carrières
c'est à dire l'adaptation au parcours
individuels de chacun
qui ne rentrent pas forcément dans le
moule des des grilles et c'est donc là
mais est ce que ça veut dire autant du
mérite j'ai passé un gros nom on parle
d'enseignement mais est ce que ça veut
dire c'est vrai que le modèle français
sacralisent le recrutement par concours
en particulier l'actuel dans la fonction
publique a de plus en plus c'est vrai
mais c'est vrai que le modèle la
fonction plus française sacralise un peu
le concours et c'est vrai que ce
concours qui est souvent très difficile
à très difficile à réussir c'est une
vraie épreuve
il est une sorte de 2,2 de la belle
qu'on est certifiée comme étant
compétent et si après quel que soit
enfin mais je m'appliquais d'emploi quel
que soit son niveau on va avoir une
progression allant pas né à foix
toujours pas ce que l'on écoute concours
inter et puis année pour changer de
corps à l'inter de la fonction publique
évidemment mais c'est vrai qu'une
progression et c'est vrai que j'ai connu
et à fort longtemps au début de ma
carrière une fonction publique ont noté
les agents sur le note de 0 à 20 avec
certaines personnes qui est arrivé à
l'âge de 50 ans il avait des 19 points 5
ans quelque chose de complètement
absurde comme système mathieu c'est une
bonne nouvelle son rapport parce que ça
crée une forme de consensus comme pour
poursuivre ce que disait bruno cautrès
mais dans la classe politique ce qui n'a
pas toujours été le cas sur les
questions éducatives enfin même si là on
parle plutôt de budget et que de
questions éducatives mais en tout cas il
ya une forme de consensus désormais sur
le fait que les enseignants sont mal
payés mal géré quand on y met mal gérée
d'un point de vue des ressources
humaines
après il va falloir passer aux
propositions et à l'action et évidemment
c'est plus difficile parce que on peut
dénoncer d'un côté la gestion à la toise
des ressources humaines qui fait que
mais selon qu'on est dans tel territoire
dans telle autre qu'on est bons mauvais
qu'on est âgée ou pages et qu'on
s'implique dans c dans la vie de
l'équipe pédagogique ou quand il
implique pas on est globalement payé
pareil et ce système là il faut le dire
aussi c'est lié à une forme de cogestion
entre les syndicats de l'éducation
nationale et l'administration de
l'éducation nationale et les deux sont
plutôt d'ailleurs content que ça se
passe comme ça parce que dès qu'on
commence à faire dans la dentelle c'est
évidemment beaucoup plus compliqué c'est
une administration avec un nombre de
fonctionnaires il ment sur le cessez le
feu plus grand nombre de fonctionnaires
en france et donc c'est vrai que faire
dans la dentelle pour 800 une personne
c'est sa demande des moyens des gens qui
savent faire et et rue de grenelle on
n'a pas forcément su faire tout ça c'est
le cas à la fois la gérer les carrières
gérer les ans les ambitions des
professeurs et puis gérer les besoins
qui peuvent changer aussi d'un
territoire à l'autre dans une zone d'un
secteur scolaire à l'autre gérard
longuet pourquoi ça vous gêne est tout à
l'heure que j ce que vous prenez la
défense des professeurs parce que c'est
ce qui nous intéresse la commission des
finances c'est le coup rendement du
système de l'éducation en france j'aime
beaucoup les professeurs mais j'aime
aussi les élèves
j'aime les parents d'élèves je suis
d'ailleurs moi-même parents et grands
parents d'élèves et donc c'est pas les
professeurs en tant que tel c'est le
système dans son ensemble alors
premières observations
les professeurs en france nous avons à
mon avis trop d'heures de cours annuels
ce qui explique le fait que nos
enseignants soient mobilisés sur des
durées annuelles importantes et pas
assez d'heures de présence des
enseignants dans l'établissement parce
que par exemple regardez l'allemagne
les salaires moyens sont entre 30 et 50%
supérieur à pouvoir d'achat et gafsa les
salaires des enseignants à l'école
élémentaire par exemple début de
carrière c'est trente et un mille euros
en france et 65000 euros en allemagne
oui c'est pas tout à fait ça l'asile à
favre ocde oui c'est l'essai de oui
enfin ce que je veux dire surtout c'est
qu'en allemagne l'enseignant est attaché
à l'établissement effet ses 40 heures
dans l'établissement ce qui fait qu'ils
assument des fonctions qui sont
extraordinairement utile à la réussite
des élèves en dehors de la présence à
dire que nous nous divisons la relation
entre l'enseignant et ses élèves dans la
classe alors qu'il y a un énorme travail
à faire entre enseignants d'une part
poursuivre les élèves et parfois entre
l'enseignant et l'élève en tête à tête
ou voir avec ses parents est ce que je
voudrais le nombre d'heures de cours en
classe je pense qu'il nous avons
peut-être trop d'heures de cours en
classe dans le primaire en particulier
avec des enfants il suffit d'être
parents d'élèves pour le savoir des
enfants qui sont très chargés en
revanche lorsque la classe est fini tout
s'arrête or les élèves ont besoin
d'avoir un contact avec les enseignants
et les enseignants ont besoin de
travailler entre eux mais ça prend
beaucoup de temps oui d'ailleurs ça crée
une inégalité puisqu'il ya des familles
qui ont les moyens de payer en tellement
des cours privés c'est encore un oui
en effet les parents n'ont pas d'âme et
ma place je dirais différemment de vous
dire les parents n'ont pas la même
implication pour le succès de leurs
enfants quand vous voyez par exemple que
dans des banlieues des familles issues
de l'immigration choisissent l'école
privée c'est parce qu'ils veulent et ça
leur coûte il veut le succès de leur
enfant et vous avez un versement des
bobos sympathique qui ont des revenus
élevés qui ne s'occupe pas vraiment de
leurs enfants dans des familles
recomposées compliqué à gérer vos lions
sk est ce que vous êtes d'accord il
cette idée réduire le nombre d'heures de
classe finalement pour consacrer du
temps à
l'accompagnement des élèves en dehors du
court sacralisé pour reprendre le terme
de géra dans l'est je dirais que il faut
avoir une vision de l'éducation qui soit
beaucoup plus globale et on peut pas
demander aux enseignants de résoudre
tous les problèmes de la société c'est
leur est notamment de réduire les
inégalités
auxquelles ils sont confrontés ne serait
ce que par la carte scolaire les
inégalités
d'accès au logement la ségrégation
spatiale et c'est finalement on demande
aux enseignants de résoudre ça sans
beaucoup de moyens alors évidemment
après il ya une difficulté à s'y
retrouver pour eux parce que on leur dit
ah lala d'école reproduit les inégalités
comme si c'était de leur faute donc je
pense que là par rapport aussi un
certain découragement enseignants il
faut qu'on soit un peu plus tranquille
par rapport aux missions qui sont qui
sont les leurs et à ce titre je pense
qu'il faut qu'il y ait d'autres
politiques qui viennent en appui en
soutien au tour pour faire en sorte que
tout cela ne pèse pas sur leur poids et
notre sur l'or sur leurs épaules et
notamment le fait qu' on puisse avoir
une meilleure gestion mais un meilleur
accompagnement de l'ensemble des élèves
notamment par rapport aux devoirs par
rapport
l'accès à la culture par rapport à
l'accès au sport par rapport à la donc
que je dirais qu'on peut pas tout leur
demander après sourire revenir sur une
chose moi j'ai dit qu'il fallait
effectivement une des ressources
humaines mais je voudrais vraiment
préciser que je ne suis pas pour autant
en train de dire qu' il faudrait que les
mauvais jeu mais des ultras guillemets
enseignants soient moins payés que les
bons enseignants etc avec une
revalorisation d'une part
dans la carrière des est quand même
extrêmement dangereux s'est passé quand
même extrême le let c'est quand même
extrêmement dont on en demande aux
élèves pardon ça laisse quand même
extrêmement difficile à évaluer vous
allez demander aux élèves avec une
inspection toutes les x années non moi
je crois qu'il faut effectivement être
moi je pensais à une de ressources
humaines d'accompagnement c'est à dire
que peut-être effectivement il ya des
enseignants qui au bout d'un certain
nombre d'années et comme on ne leur
offre pas de perspectives d'évolution de
carrière en nous en ont assez d'être
dans ce rapport et c'est peut-être que
il ya des interrogations par rapport aux
méthodes et surtout et la formation des
enseignants qui a été légérement
réaugmenter en début de quinquennat
hollande mais qui reste très nettement
insuffisante et la formation tout au
long de la carrière alors vous pensez qu
on va résoudre les problèmes on va dire
à ben toi tu es un mauvais profs on paye
moi et on va résoudre les problèmes le
problème c'est quand même de de la
qualité de l'enseignement qui est encore
à l'heure aux enfants et pas de faire du
rebord tu seras - p ça n'a pas ça ne
résout rien et en plus c'est
inapplicable est ce que moi je reviens
sur le logis mairie second cassou et non
méritée mais moi je suis très favorable
au mérite mais en fait de vous poser un
vrai problème
il faut que l'école soit tient un lieu
vivant et solidaire solidaires non
seulement des enseignants entre eux avec
les parents et j'ajoute avec les élus
locaux qui ont un rôle à jouer ce que je
regrette dans l'éducation nationale
d'aujourd'hui c'est mon expérience de
président de région qui me le fais
penser c'est que vous avez d une
extraordinaire bonne l'ontt et chez les
uns et chez les autres et on ne
travaille pas ensemble parce qu'on
attend la circulaire de la rue de
grenelle alors j'aime beaucoup de
respect pour la rue de grenelle mais
qu'on ne centralise pas tout et qu'on
laisse les établissements vivre est en
effet présenté des statistiques mais le
la difficulté du mérite et je vous
rejoins de jus à la vérité c'est que une
l'éducation d'un jeune c'est une affaire
collective et le prof de gym je parle au
collège le prof de gym a autant
d'importance que le prof d'anglais bon
en revanche ce que je sais c'est pour
recruter des profs de gym on n'a pas de
difficultés parce qu'il ya des candidats
pour recruter des profs de maths on a
des difficultés parce qu'on n'a pas de
candidat et à ce moment là le problème
de l'argent se pose parce que il ya la
loi de l'offre et de la demande et ça ça
existe partout alors on était avec
agnès verdier molinié qui économise la
directrice de l'ifrap qui était avec moi
en visioconférence bonsoir je vais citer
le titre de votre livre la france
peut-elle tenir encore longtemps c'est
chez albin michel parce que il ya aussi
la question de la nuit de l'éducation
évidemment dans dans ce livre l'ifrap
qui a publié le mois dernier une étude
comparative entre la france et
l'allemagne on a commencé à en parler
est ce qu'on dépense plus ou moins que
nos voisins allemands pour l'éducation
à écouter c c'est vraiment une bonne
question parce que ce sujet des
rémunérations entre professeurs français
et allemands a été déjà pas mal abordé
dans la campagne et puis c'est aussi
l'objet un petit peu de ce rapport
sénatorial qui vient de sortir et nous à
la fondation ifrap qu'on a voulu
comparer ce qui est comparable
c'est-à-dire la masse salariale des
enseignants du public premier et second
degré en france en allemagne y compris
la part payée pour les pensions et quand
on additionne le tout est bien on à
673000 enseignants en allemagne 697000
enseignants dans le public en france on
à 54 milliards 7 de masse salariale y
compris les pensions en france 51
milliards 6 en allemagne ça fait qu'on
dépense en moyenne par professeurs et
parents plus qu'en allemagne donc là il
ya un sujet puisqu'on dépenses 78 1400
euros par enseignant en france par
enseignants du public premier second
degré quand je veux nommer et en
allemagne c'est 76 1628 latéraux et donc
ça c'est vraiment un sujet parce que on
a l'air de nous dire en permanence que
nos professeurs ne sont pas assez payés
mais finalement quand vous additionnez
les rémunérations et les cotisations de
pension et bien vous le voyez que la
france elles dépensent autant pour ses
enseignants dont il ya un problème c'est
sur l'ensemble de la carrière c'est
drôle agnès verdier-molinié parce que
j'allais vous poser la question mais
gérard longuet qui est sympathique me
l'a soufflé poser la question des
retraites donc c'est lié à la
la retraite les professeurs allemands
partent plus tard c'est ça alors les
professeurs allemands par fut tard il
donne plus d'heures de cours ils ont
plus d'obligations supplémentaires
c'est-à-dire que par exemple vous
parliez du mérite tout à l'heure nos
professeurs les certifiés par exemple
donne 18 heures de cours parfois ils
font des heures supplémentaires
d'enseignement mais par exemple on ne
leur demande pas de surveiller la
cantine comme c'est le cas pour les
professeurs allemands ils sont obligés
le faire de surveiller aussi des devoirs
ou d où des heures de permanence donc
tout ça est paré fita évidemment ça
change aussi la donne parce que il ya
beaucoup moins de personnel qui sont
embauchés en allemagne pour les
fonctions de surveillance par exemple
donc ça permet d'avoir des des
rémunérations aussi plus importante
pendant l'activité et c'est ça qui est
très intéressant c'est de voir que nous
on a préféré avoir moins d'heures
d'enseignement moins deux mois
travaillés par an et finalement des
rémunérations qui sont peut-être pas
autant sur la période d'enseignement
mais des niveaux de pension qui sont
beaucoup plus importants donc là il ya
tout un paquet de l'art définir de
manière intelligente est ce que nous
nous trouvons c'est qu'aujourd'hui il
n'y a pas du tout d'une vision globale
et par ailleurs que souvent on compare
malheureusement des rémunération
statutaire sans compter les primes sans
compter les heures supplémentaires qui
nous amène finalement débat procès on a
bien compris merci agnès verdier-molinié
vous n'avez pas forcément le retour mais
je dois vous dire que sophie taille
paulien et est très dubitative en nous
écoutant pourquoi vous prenez en
considération les pensions on sait que
le système de retraite d'aytré comme
différentes rentrer les pays donc et je
sais pas s'il faut inciter les gens qui
ont obtenu l'agrégation à surveiller la
cantine enfin je sais pas si c'est ça la
solution et puis évidemment aussi on a
énormément d'heures travaillées par les
enseignants qui le sont chez eux sans
aucun moyen d'ailleurs on l'a vu pendant
le confinement allez-y alesi la
continuité pédagogique
ok avec l ordinateur quelle connexion
quelques ailes quel logiciel commun etc
bon donc voila moi je pense
qu'effectivement il faut il faut une
réforme importante mais qu'ils soient
construites avec les enseignants hélas
aujourd'hui on a un gouvernement qui
quand même à travailler sans voir contre
les enseignants je voudrais qu'on
reparle des hausses des salaires et je
vous propose d'écouter une proposition
aucun quand même un peu fait rire au
moment où elle est sortie c'est celle
d'anne hidalgo on écoute anne hidalgo la
candidature de professeurs sera mieux
considérés
je crois possible sur la durée d'un
quinquennat de multiplier par deux le
traitement des personnes en contact
o pour commencer
d'aligner à minimes 1 le salaire des
nouveaux professeurs sur le salaire des
bac + 5 c'est par là que l'enfant
tels 23 octobre lors de son meeting à
lille bruno cautrès est en train de
devenir un thème de campagne d'une
certaine façon oui je crois
qu'effectivement je pense que la
publication de votre apport va sans
doute alimenter le débat public c'est
une bonne chose au fond à cette
présidentielle oui je trouve que c'est
plus qu'on aime l'éducation et la riche
idée je ne sais pas c'est pas un petit
sujet simple pilier au fond de la vie en
société qui est des du crâne dérange
vraiment un élément très très important
et donc je trouve que c'est une bonne
chose de voir ce thème arrivée dans la
campagne et surtout s'il est nourri avec
des données avec des comparaisons on
voit tout ce qui peut y avoir des
désaccords sur les termes de la sur les
termes de la comparaison mais la
comparaison est toujours extrêmement
utile entre pays entre pays européens et
avait quand même en toile de fond qui
est ce problème structurel dont on a
parlé de recrutement c'est à devoir
effectivement que on n'arrive pas à
recruter dans certaines disciplines et
bercé dans l'édition part dans un
terreau mais dans les disciplines
scientifiques c'est vraiment une
question de salaire parce que quand on a
vu sur ma société je comprends beaucoup
mieux gagner je l' ai vécu à titre
personnel un jour étant membre d'un jury
de recrutement qui devait recruter un
ingénieur informaticien pour
l'enseignement supérieur et la recherche
le jeune candidat que tout le monde
voulait recruter arrive on lui explique
l'échelle des rémunérations il a dit je
suis désolée de vous à vos frais pas
votre votre temps donc je n'ai vécu en
direct donc ça existe donc les
entreprises serrent des gens me disent
c'est que chaque filière équivaut à
chaque filière dans la réglementation
française du statut de la fonction
publique déjà que si vous avez quelqu'un
qui est en latin grec ses débouchés en
dehors de l'éducation nationale sont
relativement faibles si il est au
contraire linguiste dans une langue
demandé l'anglais par exemple ou le
chinois d'ailleurs et ou bien
mathématicien et il sera évidemment
sollicité orly nous ne sommes pas
outillés aujourd'hui au ministère de
l'éducation nationale comme d'ailleurs
dans les grands ministères employeur
pour séduire des gens qui sont demandées
ailleurs alors je reviens à la question
de ce thème de campagne
mathieu on on parlait pas beaucoup
d'éducation dans cette région peut-être
dans les bons termes quoi c'est ça on ne
peut pas toujours sous le bon angle en
matière d'éducation les candidats
manquent eux souvent soit soit
connaissance fine du système éducatif
soit d'imagination et du coup on parle
beaucoup souvent des moyens des élèves
en difficulté parfois des programmes
scolaires mais assez peu au fond de la
condition enseignante du métier du
métier d'enseignant prenez à droite par
exemple les républicains ils sont en
plein débat peau pour leur congrès
qu'est ce qu'on voit dans les mesures
qu'ils proposent des soins et sont à ce
titre assez exemplaire xavier bertrand
par exemple propose notamment et on a
parlé de revoir les fermetures des
classes dans les zones rurales sa vie
c'est les territoires mais papa lé là à
sion qui a pas d'enfant n'y a pas
d'école d'eric ciotti lui il veut
imposer l'uniforme le lever des couleurs
il veut rebaptiser le ministère de
l'éducation en instruction nationale on
voit bien que là aussi on est dans les
symboles la belle affaire pour les
enseignants
je crois valérie pécresse elle est
plutôt ennemis sur les savoirs
fondamentaux dont elle veut plus
d'heures de français plusieurs de
mathématiques au début du collège donne
encore comment on fait
mais c'est sûr sur le métier
d'enseignant on n'y est pas toujours à
gauche c'est souvent la verse mais la
condition enseignante elle abordée par
la question des moyens revient de voir
avec anne hidalgo qui veut donc doubler
la mise jean luc mélenchon impossible
jean luc mélenchon lui qui veut mettre
le paquet sur la formation des
enseignants diversifier les recrutements
il propose aussi des augmentations 15%
puis 15% à négocier et puis surtout une
abrogation des réformes blanquet rowland
avec un mot d'ordre en gros qu'ils aient
la même école pour tous sur tout le
territoire au nom de l'égalité fait oui
mais alors là on revient un vieux
réflexe qui veut croire que l'égalité
républicaine doit se traduire lors je
vais être un peu caricatural mais pas un
égalitarisme éducatif très que c'est
plus simple à gérer on en parlait tout à
l'heure tout le monde géré de la même
façon c'est beaucoup plus facile pour
l'administration mais la différenciation
s'est pas forcément synonyme d'
inégalité bien nos confrères faire plus
pour ceux qui ont le plus besoin laissez
le droit aux établissements eux mêmes
aux échos aux équipes pédagogiques
d'expérimenter leur donner plus
d'autonomie si la demande pour le
bénéfice des élèves ça c'est deux sont
des sujets tabous rue de nesle et en
particulier chez beaucoup de syndicats d
enseignants qui y voit une forme de
privatisation ou de libéralisation
rampante de l'enseignement mais c'est
pas forcément le cas apprenait on
parlait d'évaluation tout à l'heure dans
un établissement comment on évalue un
professeur ben on en voit un inspecteur
qui va l'évaluer sûr c'est que la façon
dont il compte dont il dispense son
cours et puis l'inspecteur repart on a
pas quelqu'un qui dans l'établissement
peut voir si ce professeur jouent le jeu
ou non un risque immédiat à ce cas pas
de chez le chef d'établissement c'est
comme les chiens et airbus n'est pas un
je n'ai pas changé je dis pas que c'est
la solution est de l'école doit sans
france transformer les entreprises mais
enfin quand vous n'avez pas de
hiérarchie c'est vrai que c'est plus
compliqué d'évaluer les gens parce que
il ya aussi des bons et des mauvais
professeurs il s'agit pas de dire qu'il
ya que de mauvais processeur du tournée
qui a que des bons mais on sait très
bien
on va on va commencer avec bruno cautrès
et plus vous dans un intéressant au plan
de l'analyse politique de cette question
c'est qu'on voit à quel point la
question de l'école a un effet de levier
formidable pour parler de choses sur
lesquelles les français sont pas
forcément en accord alors que l'école
veut symboliser le creuset républicain
dans lequel tout le monde passe mais on
voit qu'on a eu la question des
retraites qui pointeront le bout de son
nez effectivement tout de suite qui est
faut-il retouché l'âge de départ en
retraite ya la question du rapport
national et territorial dont on sait
qu'il est vraiment la grande question
politique française pour les années qui
arrivent sans doute pour la et la
décennie qui arrive cette grande
question de comment on articule et on
voit que dès qu'on parle de l'autonomie
des établissements scolaires bassett ça
dont on parle en toile de fond qui est
qu'elle qu'elle qu'elle a conduit à
mentir la vie dans donne voilà etc on a
vu la question du mérite sur lequel
aussi il ya pas forcément d'accord donc
c'est un formidable effet de levier de
ce point de vue là c'est vrai que c'est
bien que cela soit posée au moment de la
présidentielle parce que c'est un moment
où on peut d libre à discuter et
trancher sur différents différents
projets donc il est plutôt bon qu'on
entende parler de ces grandes questions
d'action publique qui nous donnaient
plus d'autonomie aux pouvoirs aux
directeurs
d'établissements sophie aux équipes
pédagogiques et enfin un droit la
difficulté avec cela et on le voit en
réalité déjà dans des territoires où il
y a finalement une sorte de concurrence
bien malgré d'ailleurs les équipes qui
font chacune de leur mieux et on voit
d'aider des personnes demande est telle
ou telle école parce qu'il ya et c est
là qu est ce qui se passe il ya ceux qui
sont au courant qu'ils sont très très
impliquée dans la vie locale etc qui
demandent des dérogations pour leurs
enfants et puis les autres qui sont pas
au courant parce que ils n'ont pas la
possibilité d'avoir accès à
l'information et donc les inégalités
elle se creuse et on le sait si on met
les établissements en concurrence les
inégalités se creusent que je serai élu
mais l'autonomie oui mais l'autonomie
elle induit l oms l indifférenciation
s'il ya une différence les gens mondiale
quel est le meilleur quel est le moins
bon et donc on rentre dans des logiques
on rentre dans des logiques we've heard
et stratégies des familles d'accéder à
la meilleure école pour leurs enfants
c'est naturel chacun veut le meilleur
pour ses enfants aussi mais j'ai vu une
bonne expérimentation de nouveaux
produits les dangers heureusement un
petit à petit vers et c'est ce qu'on
voit avec les universités et c'est ce
qu'on voit aussi avec parcours su
finalement le fait qu'on ne demande plus
l'école qui est près de chez soi parce
que c'est plus sain pour la vie
quotidienne etc on est prêt à envoyer
ses enfants à l'autre bout de la france
là je parle pour la fac mais c'est
exactement la même situation bon voila
et donc ça moi je
porte mais il ya déjà les dans les
écoles aujourd'hui chaque équipe
pédagogique doit faire un projet d'école
est spécifique pour une aiguille on peut
certes spécifiques à une équipe et donc
ce projet d'école qui chaque jour chaque
année débattu en conseil d'école il
existe et il permet la mobilisation
autour de projets de ma parole et une
seconde pardon nous interrompt vous avec
celle qu'elle se ventile un petit peu il
ya un sav des mobiles est fait de grands
signes sur le sur l'écran de contrôle
parce que voilà vous voulez réagi sur
quel sur quels points particuliers dites
moi pas écouté justement sur le fait
qu'il ya déjà de la diversité
d'enseignement heureusement avec le
privé sous contrat que nous avons déjà
aujourd'hui en france et je voudrais
souligner que dans l'étude que nous
venons de publier à la fondation ifrap
nous montrons que l'enseignement privé
sous contrat délivre un enseignement de
grande qualité et à un prix moins cher
puisque si on avait tout les élèves de
france qui étaient scolarisés dans le
privé sous contrat ça fait une économie
énorme de plus de 20 milliards d'euros
par an donc peut-être que ça devrait
nous faire cojc c'est très contrainte
huit familles du pardon nous interrompre
ce prénom mais c'est que ses parents
payent plus donc c'est pas du tout quoi
c'est pas du tout contre intuitif
puisqu'en fait il y en a qui vont pas
prenez la totalité des coûts versés à la
fois par les financements publics et
puis par les parents d'avant vous vous
rendez compte que les élèves du public
coûte beaucoup plus cher à la
collectivité
pourquoi parce qu'il ya des pensions
plus cher on en revient à la question
des retraites parce que il ya aussi
beaucoup plus de 36 heures dans le
public qui sont pas dans les élèves et
qui sont pour autant payé par les
contribuables quand il ya un peu plus de
90 mille professeurs qui sont pas devant
les élèves et qui sont pour autant
rémunérés il ya des questions au dessus
de surcoûts aussi au niveau de la
dépense locale parce qu'on dépense plus
pour les collèges et les lycées publics
que pour que pour le privé donc là une
vraie question on arrive à avoir un
enseignement de grande qualité que
publicité par les parents par les élèves
et qui pour autant beaucoup moins cher
sur notre propre sol allez donc moi j'en
appelle a déjà comparé véritablement oui
oui on a bien entendu je dois vous
interrompt pour laisser un peu la parole
à gérard longuet pas ce que vous faisiez
non non non pendant que kader des mots
signés ces arguments le mythe dans le
secteur public des enseignants qui n'ont
pas d'élèves et il faut il y a des
études qui sont faites régulièrement par
la commission des finances il y en a je
ne parle pas de détacher syndicaux je
parle de gens qui sont en instance
d'affectation qui sont en arrêt maladie
qu il y en a mais absolument pas dans le
chiffre de 90 milles 90 et 10% des
effectifs des enseignants heureusement
ce n'est pas le cas je rassure
l'excellente agnès verdier-molinié pour
lequel j'ai plutôt de la sympathie
naturellement hâlé se proposa deuxième à
13 mois je crois que il faut réhabiliter
l'école comme un établissement et la
force du privé c'est que chaque école a
une personnalité et le directeur les
enseignants et d'une certaine façon les
parents et les élèves forment en effet
une communauté parce qu'ils ont choisi
de travailler ensemble sur un certain
modèle s'est malheureusement pas le cas
du secteur public sauf si et c'est pour
ça que je suis pour la décentralisation
les élus locaux pouvait s'impliquer plus
fortement car il aurait la fierté de la
réussite de l'établissement je suis
complètement de votre avis il ya des
écoles henri iv c'était le meilleur
lycée je trouve que par hasard j'y suis
allé mais ça si
oui tout à fait en 1962 c'était un
hasard parce qu'il n'y avait pas cette y
avait pas de bobos à paris dans le
quatrième dans le 6e arrondissement
non non non c'était des gens normaux qui
habitait une ville normale aujourd'hui
c'est une ville où il n'y a que des très
riches donc
moi je suis arrivé sur paris je reviens
le fait d'avoir un bon lycée ça
stimulait les autres établissements y
compris la petite école privée dans les
gars je fais une partie de mes études
avant d'être henri iv qui se disait il
va falloir aussi parce qu'il ya
une chance que nous avons c'est très
cohérent mais vous vous retoqué fall la
majorité l'air au top le budget 2022 et
en même temps vous vous sortez ce
rapport qui prône quand même une
revalorisation des salaires des
enseignants
première c'est très simple bulle le
président de la république annonce comme
certaines des dépenses avant même
d'avoir prévenu le parlement qui jusqu'à
présent vote la loi et donc nous avons
des milliards qui tombe à les deux je
crois qu'on a évalué une trentaine de
milliards depuis le 1er octobre on
aurait aimé qu'ils fussent intégrées
dans le budget qui nous est présenté ce
n'est pas le cas c'est un acte politique
cela le rejet de ce n'est pas totalement
au hasard tout
est le terreau est arrivé tiens
d'ailleurs je crois que c'est déjà
arrivé fait que 2016 on sait là
c'est clairement le sénat reprochait
d'un budget qui a financé la campagne de
très sympathique mais il invente tous
les matins des décisions qui ne sont pas
de sa compétence et il dépense un argent
qui n'est pas le sien bon
c'est de bonne guerre dans ces périodes
de deux d'élection présidentielle c'est
la vie démocratique on va on aime tous
au fond que la campagne électorale soit
assez animé s'il ya des controverses
tout ça c'est très bien formidable mais
c'est vrai que c'est vrai qu'on voit
monter le thème progressivement le thème
de la dette qui est un thème dans lequel
la droite pense qu'elle est dans son
jardin que c'est le thème sur lequel les
français l'attendent sur lequel elle est
perçue comme étant vraiment chez elle
sur les questions de moins d'impôts man
déficit - des gones dépenses publiques
et c'est vrai que clairement dans une
droite qui est en train de choisir son
candidat à la présidentielle serait armé
sur une question qui écoeure de 6 pour
son électorat me semble c'est
stratégique sophie ly thaï polluants
vont rejeter ce budget pour les mêmes
raisons mais nous nous avons souhaité
rejeter ce budget par cohérence parce
que nous sommes en total désaccord avec
les politiques menées il ya quand même
beaucoup de convergences entre la droite
sénatoriale et le gouvernement et
notamment ce qui rend incompréhensible
le rejet des recettes parce que sur les
recettes ils sont d'accord il faut
absolument baisser les impôts baisser
les impôts baisser les impôts et surtout
sur le capital surtout donner aux
entreprises sans aucune conditionnalité
et là il ya un accord manifeste sur sur
l'orientation après évidemment sur les
dépenses le gouvernement macron
effectivement lâche des choses mais il
promet l'austérité quand il envoie en
avril dernier le programme de stabilité
à l'europe il promet que la suite sera
très difficile et très autoritaire pour
les français il faut pas qu'ils s'y
trompent les français à suivre merci
beaucoup à tous d'avoir participé à ce
débat mais ce merci à agnès
verdier-molinié j'appelle le titre de
votre livre la france peut-elle tenir
encore longtemps c'est chez albin michel
et moi je réponds on l'espère allez
merci à tous rester avec nous tout à
l'heure